mais il n'y a pas de véritable misère
chez les Indiens car il existe une forte
solidarité qui passe aussi par la
pratique religieuse
[Musique]
la communauté en France compte environ
100000 membres 50 000 d'entre eux vivent
en Île-de-France depuis une dizaine
d'années le passage Brady dans le 10e
arrondissement de Paris et l'image bien
vivante de cette immigration
une petite Inde disons c'est on en
trouve pas partout en c'est pas comme le
China Town je veux dire c'est plus grand
là c'est tout petit c'est une
concentration de d'asiatiques de
d'indien de Pakistanais donc ça
intéresse les Français
c'est mon père qui était cuisinier de
l'ambassadeur et ensuite il a suivi
l'ambassadeur à en France il est arrivé
à Paris avec un de ses amis juste une
visite comme ça et il est tombé donc sur
des locaux du passage Brady le passage
était déserté à l'époque Antoine
punosamy arrive en France en 1973 il
loue un magasin pour en faire une
épicerie puis il achète les murs
il Acquier un deuxième local donc il
fait un restaurant Pondichérien qu'il
vendra plus tard un pakistanais
et encore un autre cette fois ça sera un
magasin d'artisanat c'est ainsi qu'il
devient propriétaire de la majeure
partie des boutiques du passage il fait
alors venir des membres de sa famille
pour l'aider et nous quelques locaux
commerciaux à des amis
cependant il est le seul parmi les
pondichériens à tenir une épicerie
qui ont la nationalité française
préfère devenir fonctionnaire pour
pouvoir toucher une retraite et ensuite
retourner au pays alors il travaille
dans la fonction publique ça peut être
professeur d'école ou
inspecteur peu importe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en France je suis arrivé 1985 et ensuite
j'ai travaillé un peu rue ressentir il y
a des Pakistanais et indiens également
là-bas et là depuis une dizaine d'années
ils sont plantés dans la restauration
donc à ma connaissance il y a une bonne
centaine de restaurants à Paris et
région parisienne
[Musique]
les Pakistanais sont généralement
pizzaïolo ils travaillent dans les
entreprises de nettoyage industriels ils
sont aussi coiffeurs cependant il
n'habite pas le quartier mais plutôt
Sarcelles Villiers-le-Bel gare je les
connais soit Alfortville
[Musique]
il travaille également dans les ateliers
de confection du sentier c'est une main
d'oeuvre bon marché car beaucoup sont
clandestins
[Musique]
chaque matin le passage du Caire se
transforme en Bourse du travail où
chacun se tient prête à effectuer des
travaux de manutention
[Musique]
mais il n'y a pas de véritable misère
chez les Indiens car il existe une forte
solidarité qui passe aussi par la
pratique religieuse
[Musique]
c'est le temple qui lit la vie de la
communauté
100 ans qu'on pourrait faire donc même
le mariage
naissances liée avec le temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça n'existe pas saison des pratiques ce
sont des croyances et puis on essaie de
symboliser ses croyances en Dieu voilà
donc si vous voulez tous les dieux
indiens ce sont des symboles où on peut
chanter on peut parler
parce que on demande quelque chose si
elle nous fait pas on peut se mettre en
colère
le seul temple à Paris dédié au dieu
Ganesh a été fondé en 1985 dans une
ancienne boucherie du 18e arrondissement
il se déroule quotidiennement trois
cérémonies Ganesh le dieu a tête
d'éléphant et le fils de Shiva il a le
pouvoir de lever les obstacles il est le
dieu du savoir et de l'intelligence
ok au début de chaque entreprise c'est
le patron des commerçants des écoliers
et des écrivains
[Musique]
à la fin du mois d'août a lieu la fête
de Ganesh c'est un dieu heureux et ça
fait l'une des plus importantes il est
particulièrement vénéré par les Tamouls
cette procession à travers les rues des
18e et 10ème arrondissement a réuni
cette année plus de 2000 personnes dans
un mélange enivrant de couleurs et de
parfum qui feraient presque croire que
l'on est au bord du Gange à Bénarès
[Musique]